>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR
FINAL EXAM WHERE WE TROLL
THE HALLWAYS OF FOX NEWS TO
LOOK FOR PEOPLE TO BRING
THEM HERE FOR CLASH OF
PERSONALITIES.
THIS WEEK'S TWO TIME
DEFENDING CHAMPION IS CARLEY
SHIMKUS.
CHALLENGER IS THE POLITICAL
EDITOR OF TOWN HALL AND FOX
ARE YOU READY.
>> READY BORN READY.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE THE
>> I WOULD LIKE TO DEFEND
THAT TITLE.
>> Tucker: HERE ARE THE
RULES.
I'M TELLING YOU SO THERE ARE
THE FIRST ONE TO BUZZ IN
GETS TO ANSWER.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I
FINISH ASKING THE QUESTION
BEFORE DO YOU.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH
ONE POINT.
GET IT WRONG YOU LOSE A
POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> READY.
>> Tucker: LET'S GET
STARTED.
THE WHITE HOUSE RECENTLY
ASKED THE GOING HEIM TO
BORROW A PAINTING TO BY
VINCENT VAN GOGH.
THE MUSEUM DECLINED INSTEAD
OFFERED PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHICH PIECE OF SO-CALLED
ART?
CARLEY?
>> 18 KARAT GOLD TOILET.
FUNCTIONING GOLD TOILET.
THIS WORK OF ART DISPLAYED
AT PUBLIC RESTROOM AND IT
HAD BEEN USED BY THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: HOW DID YOU KNOW
>> Tucker: WE DON'T DEAL IN
THAT CURRENCY HERE.
HE IS A MAN.
TOMATO, TOMATO.
>> Tucker: THIS WEEK FIRST
LIEWRNL ECLIPSE OCCURRED
THERE IS A NAME FOR THIS
PHENOMENON.
WHAT IS IT GUY BENSON?
>> IT IS A SUPER BLUE BLOOD
MOON.
>> Tucker: TOO WEIRD BUT
LET'S SEE IF YOU ARE RIGHT.
THE TAPE.
>> YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
SUPER BLUE BLOOD MOON.
FIRST TIME WE HAVE SEEN THIS
IN THE NEWS MORE THAN 150
YEARS.
HERE IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
RIGHT HERE ABOVE NEW YORK.
>> COOL.
>> REALLY COOL.
>> Tucker: HOW DID YOU KNOW
THAT?
>> BECAUSE SOMEONE MADE THE
JOKE THAT I'M SORT OF
BLUE-BLOODED AND THIS IS MY
MOON.
>> WOW.
>> THIS SPEAKS TO YOU, TOO.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: I SEE A SUPER BAD
BLOOD MOON RISING KIND OF
THING.
HOUR AND 20 MINUTES
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS WAS LONG
BUT IT WAS NOT THE LONGEST
IN HISTORY.
WHICH FORMER PRESIDENT STILL
HOLDS THAT TITLE?
GUY BENSON?
>> BILL CLINTON.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU SURE.
>> I THINK SO.
>> Tucker: NO EQUIVOCATING
IN YOUR ANSWERS.
IS IT BILL CLINTON?
>> THE HOUR AND 20 MINUTE
SPEECH, THE THIRD LONGEST
STATE OF THE UNION EVER
BEHIND TWO BILL CLINTON
SPEECHES.
>> OH.
>> HE HAS SPOTS ONE AND TWO?
>> ONE AND TWO, YEAH.
>> Tucker: THAT'S
CLINTONTONIAN.
I'M NOT SURPRISED, ACTUALLY.
OBAMA I FELT LIKE.
BUT NO ONE BEATS CLINTON IN
THAT CATEGORY.
ONE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN
ADVISORY OUGHT TO BE AIRED
BEFORE HIS SPEECHES.
WHO IS THIS CONGRESSWOMAN?
>> MAXINE WATERS.
>> MAXINE WATERS OF LOS
ANGELES?
>> YES.
>> THIS PRESIDENT WITH HIS
VULGARITY AND HIS DISRESPECT
FOR WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR IS A TERRIBLE ROLE
MODEL FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THAT SAYS THIS MAY NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE FOR CHILDREN.
>> YES.
THAT'S NOT EXTREME.
>> Tucker: NO.
>> TOTALLY.
>> Tucker: ARE WE TWO TO
>> Tucker: WE ARE.
CONFIRMED THAT TWO TO TWO.
QUESTION.
PALMS ARE SWEATING.
HERE IT IS.
A VIDEO OF A RAT, THE RODENT
WENT VIRAL THIS WEEK BECAUSE
THE RAT WAS CAUGHT DOING
SOMETHING PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY.
WHAT WAS THE RAT DOING?
>> AN.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE RISKY
BECAUSE I KNOW I WOULD BE
DOCKED A POINT.
>> Tucker: IN FACT INDEED
PRESSED.
>> SO I HAVE TO ANSWER.
THERE IS SOMETHING IN THE
BACK OF MY MIND THAT SAYS
THAT I READ SOMETHING ABOUT
SOMETHING TO DO WITH A
CIGARETTE.
HE HAD A CIGARETTE.
NOT PIZZA RAT.
>> YEARS AGO.
>> Tucker: WAS THE RAT
SMOKING A CIGARETTE?
ANY KIND OF CIGARETTE WAS
THE RAT SMOKING?
>> REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
OF HAIRY LIKE THIS FELLOW.
LOOK AT HIM PREPARING FOR
HIS DATE.
HE IS GETTING ALL THE
IMPORTANT SPOTS.
MARRIAGE.
AND HE JUST MET SOMEBODY
ONLINE.
AND.
>> IS HE BATHING.
>> MOUSE CLIP AWAY.
>> CUTEST RAT EVER.
>> NOT A DIRTY HABIT BUT
CLEAN HABIT.
HITTING THE COCAINE BAR BUT
NO.
>> I WANT TO SEE THE
INDIVIDUAL OVERTHE RAT
SMOKING A CIGARETTE.
>> I SAW SOMETHING MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A JOKE BASED ON
THAT.
>> Tucker: IT WAS A BOLD
GUEST IN THE END IT DID NOT
PAY OFF.
>> Tucker: CARLEY SHIMKUS
YOU REMAIN FOR THE THIRD
WEEK IN A ROW.
UNBELIEVABLE.
AGAIN, THE COVETED MOUTH
BREATHING MUG.
>> MY CUPBOARDS ARE FULL.
>> Tucker: GIVE THEM TO YOUR
FRIENDS.
>> THAT WAS GREAT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PAY ATTENTION TO THE NEWS